Fox News has been going out of its way
to avoid telling the truth about Trump
Russia and out of its way to avoid
visitors to its website from even being
allowed to post the truth about Donald
Trump Jr's meeting with that Russian
lawyer and Russian lobbyist there was a
sentence this is obviously very
high-level and sensitive information but
as part of Russia and its government
support for mr. Trump that was a line
from one of the emails that Donald Trump
jr. was involved in and that sentence
was blocked from Fox News's web site
they set up some kind of an auto filter
that would remove that line from its
comment section and they conveniently
are not including that part of the email
in articles about this the filter was
first discovered by a Reddit user who
goes by the name eff all Nazis which is
an interesting username in and of itself
and the filter was set up not just on
stories about the Trump Russia meeting
but even on stories that have nothing to
do with that whatsoever so that's number
one Fox News by and large going out of
its way to censor the truth about Trump
Russia
there's however ease on this dot-dot-dot
win between that no matter how they
wrote it the autofilter' was updated to
pick it up people tried to reword it
slightly or an ellipses or whatever not
allowed on the Fox News website however
there are kind of shockingly some people
on Fox News at least trying to tell the
truth about what's going on with Trump
Russia which is that this is a major
scandal of epic and historic deception
I'm going to play this clip for you this
is Shepard Smith talking to Chris
Wallace and they were sort of making an
effort to just be upfront about the
level of deception that was going on
take a look at this we've been told of a
variety of stories we've gotten and who
knows if we're if we've gotten to the
end of the story we only have to be a
nightmare no details I know that we have
it because there's news breaking at this
moment correct okay fox news can now
confirm knew more Donald Trump jr. Jared
Kushner Paul Manafort the lawyer from
Russia the interpreter this new guy we
found out about today and a mystery
person
john roberts confirms there was an
eighth person in that meeting we don't
know there may have been more but there
was an eighth Jared Kushner filled out
his form
I think it's an f-86 saying who he'd met
with and what he'd done very important
stuff you can go to prison for messing
it up
you know intentionally he went back and
added 100 names in places none of these
people made it still not clear we're
still not clean on this Chris it's if
there's nothing there and that's what
they tell us they tell us there's
nothing to this and nothing came of it
there's a nothing burger it wasn't even
memorable didn't write it down didn't
tell you about it because it wasn't
anything so I didn't even remember it
with a Russian interpreter in the room
at Trump Tower if all of that why all
these lies what why is it lie after lie
after lie if you clean come on clean you
know my grandmother used to say when
first we practice to oh what a tangled
web we weave when first we practice to
deceive
the deception risk is is mind-boggling
and there are still people who out there
who believe we're making it up and one
day they're going to realize we're not
and look around and go where are we and
why are we getting told all these laws
you know I don't know what to say I
think that that there's a lot of that of
truth to everything that you've said the
rest of the network is still in blame
Hillary for everything mode and even
better blame Obama if you can britt hume
has shifted from there was no collusion
to if there was collusion it wouldn't be
illegal anyway so who cares but at least
for now Shep Smith and Chris Wallace are
saying what they think right-wingers on
Twitter immediately calling for their
firing and/or resignations Kushner could
be led away in handcuffs by the feds and
Fox News would come out with breaking
bombshell Hillary did something kind of
similar a few years ago or breaking
Obama didn't physically stop Trump from
meeting with Russians so he's really the
guy to blame but the truth is it's
getting pretty unavoidable at this point
some common sense is bound to seep
through even on Fox News you know this
was just about the meeting I think they
would have a case to be made to defend
the White House here they could go to
the talking points of well
collusion is not a crime they didn't get
any valuable information out of that
meeting and while those are easily
debunked they could still make that case
yeah but the lies are what makes this
indefensible and I think you know some
people with a little bit of intellectual
honesty like Shep Smith and like Chris
Wallace they're able to fess up to that
I really hope Shep Smith doesn't
accidentally stabbed himself in the back
ten times I really hope he doesn't
because it is this level of honesty is
not looked upon favorably by Fox News by
the Fox News audience and by any players
who want to cover up what is now in in
writing evidence of collusion between
Russia and the Trump campaign today's
program is made possible in part by
Gamefly which is sort of like netflix
for video games
they've got over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can also stream games you don't even
need a gaming console or a computer
because you can stream games through
your Amazon fire stick or Roku box and
then use your mobile phone as the
controller you can play as many games as
you want for one monthly fee and if you
find some games you want to keep you can
buy them for a low used price never with
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a 30-day free trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included no contracts and you
can also stream the games I think I
mentioned that you can also rent games
through the mobile app get a free 30-day
trial for david pakman show viewers and
listeners and support our show at
Gamefly offer.com forward slash TDP s